hot breath i would love for you just to
break down maybe storytelling
from just a master like you i mean and
that's and that's the thing
people have been saying this lately they
like yo man you are
a phenomenal storyteller and
at first i didn't know how to take that
i'm like uh are you saying i'm lying
that's what i would be like you're the
new comment yeah but i'm the new jones
so
the so it's like you're you're joking
you live in a gated community now as
well which is hilarious which is
freaking hilarious
you have a story about the like the
neighborhood coming to drop you off
baked goods and you call the police and
all this
so maybe even break down how you develop
that into a story from paper to stage
this is this is what actually this is
how that story
actually took place okay so
i'm literally living in this i moved in
this gated community
and you you go in it was like
i just i'm like yo i haven't seen any
other
black people over here hit my girl she
was like
i know right and i'm like
why the hell okay how did we find this
and she's like
it was on the brochure and so she showed
me the brochure in the brochure got
everybody on there literally like
literally doing all type of [__] you
flipping through the brochures all type
of
people doing random different [__] that
they would be doing
but it's none of them oh it's like all
continually always so
and then i'm coming home one day and
the p they didn't let me negate
and the lady was like do you live over
here
i'm like um the only one
that's all i'm like the only one ma'am
i should it should be so easy for me to
get in this game because i am
the only one and
if you see another black person coming
to this thing they're probably with me
they probably know me then so then i
start
you know something i am the only black
person over here so i just wrote the top
down
only black person in my neighborhood
okay it's gated
they didn't let me in the gate
do they think people can't jump this
gate
so i'm just writing down things that i'm
thinking okay like
why they don't lock these stuff up and
then i'm like
this is weird then i start oh
okay um did this lady just ask me that
was a trail mix
no and i'm piecing it
together and i'm looking at it
and i said that's crazy i live in a
gated community with all these people
and i know they gonna change this is my
little thought
i know they're gonna change me i know it
i know they're gonna change me i know
[__] about me that i like i know they
gonna [__] with it i know it
because i was saying they are so
inviting and then i would get up
in the morning and literally everybody's
walking around
the [__] just walking i'm like i'm
not i'm not going out there
i'm not doing it it's it's too early
it's too pleasant i'm not doing it
i go out there and i'm like what y'all
doing
and i'm seeing just and then i just
start looking
at where i live and every day i would
just come in i just find
something else about it i'm like this is
crazy so then i was on stage when i
i'm like i know eventually people are
gonna find out where i live at
and i don't want y'all to judge me
because i live
in a gated community and i'm the only
black person over there and i say i know
i know but they tricked me
because the brochure was very
multicultural right
yeah so then i'm just start piecing it
together wow
and then the the guy knocked on my door
with some other people it was like maybe
like six people
with this welcome basket welcome to the
neighborhood [__]
and i was in there because i was high
i'm smoking
and i'm like i wanna know what they want
i thought
like well we're going to just leave your
basket and your stuff at the door
we don't know if you're busy or not
why would they be doing that why would
somebody
why would somebody just hollow through
your door now
crack the door what's happening
oh we're the welcome committee and i'm
like this [__] is crazy
i've been in the hood all my life
nobody's ever [__] welcomed me to the
neighborhood
so it's just the the putting it and
seeing it
and piecing it together and being able
to tell it very fluid
from beginning to end
with no real point
it's no punch line it's no i don't i'm
not writing punch lines in it
i'm telling the story
first and then i start thinking about
the parts that could be funny
but as i'm telling the story i'm telling
the dry story
and it goes back to when you're not
being funny
be interesting because whatever you say
that's interesting eventually
turn funny because you jovial anyway
so i'm telling the story and then it
gets to these
pieces of when people will be like oh
[__]
and then you list you looking at the
audience and you see them like
yeah they're leaning in so
damn so and then the
the only part of the whole story which
is the part that's the weakest the
weakest part of this whole story is very
weak because i don't do it all the time
because i'm not i don't trust it is the
part where i start
saying um because this is when it
becomes
jokey to me like when you start seeing
people outside your door you start
hallucinating and i'm like i know
for some reason i was saying she there
wasn't there i saw a burning cross
i just saw white people it was a
pitchfork and then um
i'm i'm thinking in my mind they they
they
calling me to come out and i'm trying to
find my
my gun and i got three bullets and i'm
sitting up against the thing and i'm
saying
why do you ain't gonna take me out of
here like that and
it's it's the weakest part of it
because it's the joke part the rest of
it is the actual story
which is good and then i try to add the
joke [__] to it then he's like
no so i never tell that story
i tell the story about when i came home
late at night and i said you always when
you sleepy
just go to sleep don't try to do [__]
because i'm in my house and i put on i
want some tuna fish for some strange
reason at
[__] four o'clock in the morning i put
on some eggs
put some boiled eggs on for putting my
tuna fish and i'm watching sportscenter
and i said i'm [__] dead sleep by the
second
dun dun dun dun
but i got guns all over my house just in
case somebody break in
and i want to be vulnerable nowhere and
remember i'm asleep and i left them eggs
on
and most people know when eggs the water
boil all the way down
the eggs pop they start popping
it sound just like that so i'm
[__] disillusioned i think it's my
shooting that means i didn't drop down
off the couch and i grabbed my 38
from up under the bed and my mom's in
the guest room
and she comes out what's going on and i
hear
i say go back mama they shooting in here
these [__] wow
you're excited though you're like
finally so then nostalgia
i said to myself cause i'm i'm in this
it's funny how you can be
intoxicated in sleep mm-hmm
you get up and you you ever you ever
been late
for work but you're really not late
because you you running out the house
you in the car you go and you realize
it's [__] saturday
yeah and you didn't did all you didn't
got dressed you in a vehicle
you're mobile and you literally still
drunk unconscious
and you like i'm gonna be late i'll be
late i'm like
it's saturday damn
so with storytelling
you start from the beginning and you be
as
intricate as possible
you tell the very smallest
minute points because that's what makes
the story
authentic because you you
like when somebody like i [__] hate
oranges new black because i know it's
not
one i hate the [__] name that's
racist [__]
i'm saying why would orange be the new
black tell me why howard orange are you
trying to say black people are [__]
locked up what are you trying to say
but i digress but
the way i hated oz and i hate it
orange new black equally because i know
it does not go like that
and i'm sitting like who's telling these
fictitious ass stories
so you grew your nails long and you
slash somebody
in their face like
stop so with your stories you try to
just use as many details
as possible is that where the did um
did i do did i do prison intake did i do
the intake story
because i know i'm doing that on my
special so i know i'm working it i don't
think so
i might about being naked toe heel to
toe
no i didn't hear that one oh so heel to
is is something that's gonna be on my
special that's filmed out of prison by
the way let's go we're going filming at
a prison we're trying to get this
clearance
um so if anybody know anybody um in
texas who knows anything about being
trying to get one so bad for comedy
central which the turnaround is quite
fast you do a half hour this year and
then the next year you have an hour
that's that's a pretty fast turnaround
i don't know if many people jump that
quick i i've been hearing that
i've i've really been hearing that but
i'm i'm
very very ready for you are you
you should have a ton of material so
that that aspect of it
they intrigue because they know that i'm
saying
it's other people that have been to
prison that look and be like
yeah that should happen because
he he actually knows like he he knows
knows like it's not like
it's not like this the separate thing is
like
i don't want people to think that like
i'm like any other person that tells
or a prison store like oh uh like you're
like well kevin's told that story about
his uncle being in jail
different [__] women tell the story
about
um having a boyfriend he locked up and
he got all the
they're they're telling very general
[__] right
right you know you they keep their room
nice and tidy and all
that's very general [__] anybody [__]
watch any prison show
knows that but
how do i get from point a to point b
what my sale look like what else would i
do to my sale
you know what what would i actually do
how's my sales set up
what's the what's the what's the social
dynamics
of this place what's the social dynamics
everybody like yo you know you all go
you know this fight
it's not really i tell stories about
places where i came from a unit where
people were fighting
and then somebody said hey man we don't
do that over here
we only kill we don't fight we
only kill and this that's a that's a
real conversation
then somebody telling you it intake hey
man get you a knife
and where to go get it from and how to
get it and somebody telling you
what it's gonna be made from and how you
gonna make it and all of this real
technical [__] that you cannot possibly
know unless you're there yeah like cece
cece get it from cc